[Music]
when sire moves us to the new world
I'm gonna need names
I mean
eight nine two one two it's not really a
name
so
I would like my name to be
Lila
Lila Lila
that's a pretty name Lila
thank you
I think my name shall be Thieves
because although we all do have them
mine are definitely the most prominent
teams thiefs Lila thieves
you're lying on a floor so your name is
floor
[Music]
Someday I'm gonna make great machines
that fly
and me and my friends are gonna go
flying together
into the forever and beautiful sky
Lila
tips
and floor
and me
rocket
rocket it really is good to have friends
yeah
[Music]
I'm gonna tell you something
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
[Music]
met a girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
came back a totaled dick
oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
want to make things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
I said something
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
we're always searching for a family and
how we found each other
are you ready
for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
and beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into though
knock it off what
just never noticed how black your eyes
were they were replaced by my father as
a method of torture he he picked a
pretty set
[Music]